whenever shohei ohtani tows the rubber
you can expect great things solid record
for sure and even better here at home
yeah he's throwing the ball in his
entire career very very well here at the
big a but this season has been great 5-0
5-0-1-9-2 era first pitch from the big a
grounded up the first base line and
that's a nice cc out we got a guy there
jared walsh and one pitch one down well
you love those quick outs of your show
hey otani especially you can get some
quick outs with your fastball early on
it's a good hitter and isaiah keiner
falefa
reached for that one
it's an easy out right there for walsh
two down
two down runner on first so the batter
now will be
nathaniel lowe their first baseman he's
hitting 261.
right up the middle oh that that hit
showway does he does he have enough time
he might
did he gets him
shoei otani hopefully he's okay he's
looking at the hand there the rangers
are challenging that play it has been
overturned so it is an infield hit for
nathaniel lowe
meanwhile
the angels are out
looking at ohtani looks like shoei
otani's okay so he's going to stay in
there two outs first and second can he
get out of this one big moment right
here early in this game
ground ball got a guy there
shoei otani gets out of it two infield
hits and two men left there is the
rookie glen otto getting ready to make
his second big league start there's
david fletcher first up he's 10th in the
league and batting at 291 right-handed
hitter
he's not going to get over his head that
is space hit for david fletcher just
over the outreached arm of isaiah kinder
for left and here's otani
getting 260 with a major league leading
42 home runs
he hits his ball sharply on the ground
diving stop solac he'll take the one out
at first
so they get ohtani so gossel now with
one away a chance to drive in fletcher
there it is face it rbi single for phil
gosselin it's one nothing angels
up now is jared walsh
runner on first
oh i think that's going to get through
oh late read from dawson are they going
to send it butterfield does boston on
his way to the plate here's the throw oh
he's going to make that standing up rbi
there it is number 80 for jared walsh
and the halos take a two nothing lead
jason martin the batter hitting 185 five
homers and 13 runs batted in
pitch to martin that one will leave the
infield might well lead the yard back
near the wall looking up lagaras it's
gone
[Applause]
martin with his sixth home run of the
year
and he ties the game at two in the
second inning that's a thing of beauty
right there jason martin jumping on the
first pitch that he sees from shohei
ohtani this is one of the top prospects
in the rangers organization leote
tavares
and that'll do it that's that splitter
he's throwing two of them in this inning
well that's nasty that's 63 strikeouts
versus his splitter this year john
hernandez up for the second time
i think so
back-to-back strikeouts but the rangers
tie it up
man is on better now will be garcia
that could be two
gosselin
fletcher good point there by
jared walsh that's a twin killing right
there that's exactly what shohei needed
nathaniel lowe always dangerous
and here's the pitch a swing and a miss
fastball he throws it by him that had a
little extra on it
so fletcher is on here to start the home
half of the third in this tie game two
two and here's shohei ohtani
this one on the ground could be two the
second one on the first double play and
that's a
five
six three double play you don't see that
one very often now here's jonah well
pitch at bat ohtani's 2-2
this is popped in the air into shallow
right field should be a routine play
camping under making the catch on that
one is juan legaris so after all that
and boy that was a lengthy matchup heim
it's a routine shallow fly ball to right
field the rangers have
a pair of runners in scoring position
second and third for martin
right now you have the man that hit the
two-run home run
got him
fastball 100 come on wow that's dialing
it up a little bit runners in scoring
position 100 miles an hour let's see if
he can get out of this jam here ninth
hitter is leote tavares here's the next
pitch he chops this one on the right
side it's right at wall he'll beat him
to the bag and that is how the inning
ends so
shohei pitches out of a
one-out
situation right now it's adolescarcia
who
has 29 home runs two outs here in the
fifth next pitch
and that is a called third strike shohei
picks up strikeout number five so let's
see what shohei can do he can help his
own cause right here
doesn't get any better than this moment
right here
joey or johnny
i just missed that one to right field
that ends the ending just off the end of
the bat max dassey looking to give the
angels a big time lead and help out
shoei otani how clutch would this be
bottom six ground ball could be trouble
in the hole that's going to be a tough
play
just take the lead there's joe adele
showing that emotion that was absolutely
clutch it's been showtime here tonight
without a doubt nick solak steps in got
him pitch
number 99
fans loving it martin jumped on the
first pitch against him as first at bat
got to be careful here if you're
oh that's lined out to right field and
that's going to drop right in front of
lagarus that's a base hit it's the first
hit he is allowed on an o2 count this
year leote tavares who he has done very
well against this young 22 year old
wanted two one out
runner on first
got him looking
gets the goal that's the second time
he's gotten that call there's some late
movement on the splitter first and
second two outs one and two to kinder
philetha ground ball
walsh has it oh tommy
he covers the bag beautiful feed from
walsh
seven headaches from shohei ohtani
[Applause]
two down in the night
iglesias
angels win 3-2 show a otani picking up
his ninth victory he's 9-1 on the year
and it's getting lit tonight baby